20 heures de bus à 80 km/heure ce groupe
de slovaques aride de bratislava pour la
première fois un tour operator de
slovaquie a réservé une vingtaine
d'emplacements au camping rigueur de
l'est il écoute discipliner les
instructions de michel le représentant
de la gent slovaques passent on était
ici les familles dépensent mille francs
pour huit jours tout compris repart et
excursions une somme malgré tout
conséquente pour la classe moyenne s'il
y a une famille à quatre membres quand
il doit faire l'économie totale pendant
quatre mois quatre mois ils doivent
mettre leurs salaires à part alors c'est
cette jungle en sacrifice pour les repas
la moitié des denrées alimentaires a
voyagé avec les touristes
l'argent de poche est quasiment
inexistant mais l'important n'est pas de
dépenser c'est de découvrir
on est parti à mon accord à 15 anus
alors on a bien profité mais aussi on
était fatigué mais c'était très très
joli changement de décor promenade des
anglais
une promenade russe où les prix des
matelas et des parasols sont traduits
après paris yuri un homme d'affaires
d'ukraine pas sa deuxième semaine de
vacances sur la côte d'azur prix du
séjour
vingt-six mille francs pour sa famille
c'est sûr c'est un gros budget pour un
niveau de vie moyen mais nous on peut se
le permettre
les russes font escale dans les hôtels 3
ou 4 étoiles leur séjour est réglée aux
agences avant leur départ pour les
suppléments c'est différent au niveau
des dépenses en temps extra minibar
téléphone restauration tout ça s'est
fait de manière en espèces en dollars en
dollars et en région dach une publicité
pour un casino dans un magazine en russe
le signe que les valises de dollars ont
trouvé leurs marques sur la côte d'azur
de l'argent frais pour le commerce
parfois de l'argent sale selon un récent
rapport des renseignements généraux
certains touristes russes sont déjà
investis dans l'immobilier pour les
vacances bien sûr mais aussi pour
d'autres affaires plus discrète